hey good morning everyone we are back
playing our games of the year from the
past this is our game of the year from
2001 Grand Theft Auto 3 oh my goodness
oh my gosh oh my goodness let's go
that's all I'm trying to say okay let me
swap over um to the screen
look at that
alright hey everyone in chat what's
going on thank you for joining us for
GameSpot live happy Thursday
alright we're gonna start with the new
game fortunately the intro is short and
sweet so let's hop right into it huh yes
make sure the sounds okay I'm hearing
myself so the mic sounds good
let's check the audio of the game let's
go tiger in the chat a little hi there
[Music]
how's that how's that in contrast to my
voice let me know in the chat look at
that yeah
[Music]
dan already in the chat says still my
favorite quote from gta3 it's a lot more
allure man Sam Park it'll just be me
today Persia is off in Japan and I'm
taking over for the rest of week that's
just today yesterday today and tomorrow
just little ol me look at that there I
am Claude Claude speed
although I don't know I heard that name
you guys ever hear that name like the
Claude speed name and wonder where it
came from do they say it in this game I
don't know he doesn't say a damn thing
but he has a name
oh no this is not a gta3 remake we're
just playing this was our game of the
year in 2001 so we're celebrating that
by playing it today
good times tomorrow we will be playing
our current game of the year set your
own shadows die twice no no Dan this is
not a video review this is just a nice
screen here we go oh man memories with
this game you know early days of the
PlayStation for me yep Luke Charles
8-ball that's my man right there were
busting out it me and him how are we
doing today how you guys doing Chad
what's your favourite GTA of all time 5
is a really good contender 3 is the one
that started it all as far as 3d gotta
love Vice City San Andreas let me hear
it in the chat [ __ ] what do you guys
think
hi dogs Andrew that's right 2001 game of
the year
spookie you're in the right place then
spooky in the chat says Grand Theft Auto
3 for PlayStation 2 is the best here we
are a mod hi welcome to the chat welcome
to the stream thank you for joining
today you guys are ready look someone's
already told me press Start already
we're here we're at the intro chill bro
it's about to start we got some votes
for Vice City for the best story San
Andreas for the best game GTA 4 has a
good Grimm story
hell yeah see again no wrong answers
here
I like that light there we go
y'all see me yeah what's going on no no
me says never played a GTA game is that
weird a little weird I don't know how
you could have escaped it for so long
but uh if you like what you see you
should try to pick one up this game is
like I think less than 20 bucks on
PlayStation right now PlayStation 4 here
we go let me uh
keep this off maybe huh there we go
let's go our very first mission with
8-ball you guys hear me okay sure you
can let me know if you can remember this
cars it's like middle of the road car
it's not great it's not bad this is just
the car you start with
let's see where are we going skirt that
guy has a bad I'm in the wrong side of
town whoa oh I do miss the music already
though can't be doing downstream however
you guys know here we are
wait not yet watch out truck so for
today I'm just gonna play this story
maybe in the second half of the stream
or towards the end we'll have a little
fun get crazy with all the cheats you
got you guys know there's so many cheats
yeah this is the place right here
how we doing guys dan says I love the
radio in this game yeah me too Mario's
ready to jump in he said let's go after
the aku's Oh soon well hopefully you got
a new clothes
he's waiting him go back to LA to
probably get you some water
man hearing that voice acting all of
this is just like a throwback this was
this was in the days where I was like I
played this for the first time I believe
Mike
one of my cousin's had this on the ps2 I
was like yo I want a ps2 and then when
Vice City came out I said to myself okay
I'm getting a ps2 and I did here we go
mission number one we tease girls oh
yeah Danny Savage I had a folder full of
cheats every game I just wrote it down
or typed it out it was so funny folder
was like Richie's cheats like do not it
well I go in and talk to Luigi Marcin
says gta6 2020 mmm-hmm
I don't know right there there are
little tiny rumors sparking I don't know
about 2020 but why not well maybe you
could do me a favor one of my girls
needs a ride so grab a car and pick up
misty from the clinic then bring her
back here remember no one messes with my
girl Franny asks is this game laggy on
PlayStation or is it maybe is it a
little laggy I'm looks smooth to me it's
a it's a ps4 download it's available in
the PlayStation Store to play on your
Playstation 4 and is it a little choppy
a little
No maybe I hope not let's go pick up
misty oh right into this pole whoops man
can I get another car I'm sure I can
this is GTA I need some wheels yeah I
don't have to be those wheels even a
taxi is faster
oh yeah I'm ready
later top
this is not gonna like that I'm picking
her up in a cab whatever actually she
say anything vicious I'm just trying to
turn off the radio there it is Scoob hop
in
hop in a little faster Missy let's go
I'm still being chased by the cops man
I love for to this is this reminder
you're playing for obviously because
they're both in Liberty City but shout
out on the chat if you guys look for
whoa man
here we go is that it
all right watch this oh my god $1,500
for dropping off a lady like was that
two blocks away
Rizwan says the taxi is invincible yeah
absolutely
how am I gonna play with cheats on ya oh
yeah definitely I just wanted to open up
with a few missions kind of just you
know jump back into the the story all
the dialogue all the good memories
although a lot of the memories involve
cheats like I can say that personally
hell yeah
so I will be inputting some cheats what
do we got
how's everyone doing a chat whoa maybe I
should focus on the road I know one
sheet uh off the top of my head you see
here
yeah got some weapons heck yeah
sir here we are back at Luigi's place
that's gonna walk in wait where the heck
do I go has it been that long y'all here
we go ha ha will says I remember as a
child I used to think this game was a
racing game called the man runs on my
dad's PlayStation and I thought it was a
really fun racing game wow I was dumb no
man you were a kid there's a lot of cars
involved in this game it's not dumb that
sounds like a regular old kid story you
know what you call it I like your name
the man runs on the playstation 2 all
right what did I just pick up I was kind
of reading chat halfway there oh there's
my car blocking traffic okay okay jeez
is like the real New York everyone's
just honking Andy Muhammad says I love
GTA 3 hell yeah Fran you are in the
right place whoa we do too that's why
we're playing today
it was our game of the year in 2001
yeah this taxi rules
whoo I like that car though too
I miss all the pedestrian voice-acting
hope that's my car
maybe I should put my gun away nope oh
eight whoa maybe I should have read the
mission okay
it was cool to do that Sam Park maybe I
can switch to the chat channel sure
that's funny
Oh was it it looks like chatterbox
flashback yeah
these were always excellently written
but you know you guys know I'm gonna
talk over it but we can at least have
the radio on for this okay the handling
on this party little slippery Lazlo man
I thought he got a start for some reason
in a vice city as the radio host Laszlo
crud
here we go excuse me sir whoops
almost to the paint shop man over here
is that it on the quick oh that guy took
my spot oh okay it's around the corner
goodness gracious this cars about to
blow up okay that was uncalled for
we're here the talk radios are funny he
says Bray ng yes absolutely no with a
nose I can't turn on the game radio they
have a copy written music I do I get
busted I was trying to shut me down out
here
okay maybe for a second what's the best
station I'll put it on for like ten
seconds I just painted the car
okay
whoo hold
I wonder if they'll accept the car in
this condition probably not
out of my way everyone man they don't
there you go so he didn't move him
honking at him
the Banshee who the only one is on the
island man forgot about the Banshee that
thing was a beast
all right well crack the windshield will
they accept it mission passed $4,000
heck yeah
Danny seen the chat says watching this
makes me feel like I'm revisiting a
childhood home right there's that meme
that's always going around it's a map of
like this or San Andreas it's like you
know this better than your own city it's
like damn dude do I feels like it
sometimes that's right Frank all right
I'm gonna call you Frank and the chat
says I just remember that game spot was
my go-to from cheat codes that's right
this morning I was looking them up and
the it directed me to a game spot and
game facts which is now a part of the
game spot that's that's the place to be
for all these cheats
okay I'm getting punked yeah let's
figure out what to do here huh excuse me
do you know the way back to Luigi's
place okay so I did I didn't put a cheat
earlier I got guns but I'm not gonna
wile out just yet but it's so funny I
can just walk around with a sniper rifle
and it's cool with the city of new Oh a
bazooka yeah no big deal huh do
pedestrians respond on honking uh they
didn't I tried earlier that guy want to
move I need a car I need a car this is
Grand Theft Auto not grand theft running
her
man man okay I wanted his taxi
this is this guy's wiling out whoo
this cars about the blow-up I don't know
why I pick it up all these tracks are so
nostalgic goodness whoops here we go
oh yeah the game the game fax message
board was it was the social media back
in the day says Mario yeah how you doing
son Joey Leone he wants some action from
his regular girl misty go pick her up at
Hepburn Heights but watch yourself
that's Diablo turf that run her over to
his garage and Trent and make it quick
Joe ain't the kind you keep waiting
remember this is your foot in the door
do that angle like a movie so so
groundbreaking you guys ever played GTA
1 or 2 I did and I loved him and when
this came out I was like no way they
made it 3d and it was the best it was
everything I wanted I didn't get it
right away but when I did it was great
no no no I need a better car smokey I
wanted to take that taxi wait that's
enough
boy I blew it oh I thought someone took
mine taxi
awright awright awright awright
[Music]
I'm sorry Fernando has Lazlo
well that's rude let's go knock on the
door man is yo how you doing hey welcome
to the chat welcome to GameSpot live
thanks for tuning in you guys Missy's
the real protagonist says movie the
misty is video protagonist that's funny
take Missy to Joey's
Wow she's not gonna be impressed with me
y'all
that car is dope
who vice city was my first GTA - not
really I take that back I played one and
- for sure I'm as far as the let me back
up here I just got so excited about by
city by city was the last like it was
for me it was the reason I bought a ps2
that in Kingdom Hearts it made me like
actually save up enough money to get one
I did play one and two but they weren't
mine
they were they belonged to my uncle but
I did like them for what they were and
then three changed everything
what was your guys's first grand theft
auto let me know in the Czech gj1
Liberty City San Andreas and Vice City
Joey Joey I'll be with you in a minute
spark plug spark plug
hey I'm Joey the weed you said you were
reliable so comically no way that
Michael Rapaport well we've made a
friend guys well I got a cell phone does
that mean it's at the pay phone down the
street what is it where's that this is
where is it
oh that's silica that's the mission
right here that's what's ringing okay we
made a friend let's work with him huh
what are you guys are saying gt1 was
reverse they need to be taught some
respect lips Farrelly is stuffing his
fat face in the st. marks bistro so
steal his car and take it to eight balls
bomb shop up in Harwood you know 8-ball
right
once he's fitted it with a bomb go park
the car where you found it then sit back
and watch the whole sky remember this
mission up you won't be in forever man
I'm remembering this game more than I
thought like I remember obviously the
environment and Liberty City but the
actual missions like I was starting to
remember even some of the dialogue of
these early missions wavy Davy says I
played all of them every GTA since day
one dang just the bow same here well you
know what I take it back when it went
mobile I missed out on a few and I
regret it because chinatown wars is
supposed to be one of the best what are
your guys opinions but I did miss out on
the stories series you know like liberty
City Stories by city stories I goofed up
and missed them I didn't have a PSP
right away but then they eventually came
to ps2 that's cool all right
got to plant the bomb y'all take it to
the shot
yo all right can't go crazy
I wish I wish I could play the radio you
guys know all right man these locations
are really close to one another
maybe this map is smaller than I thought
what's uh is there a map layout there's
got to be mmm don't remember this is
Stan's briefs now there has to be select
nope select changes the view cute oh
that's fun
scraping up this guy's car whatever oh
those boys wonder if I can damage it
enough just a little bit before I uh
this is probably gonna happen by mistake
here doctor 360 wave says oh my god the
nostalgia hekia man we are playing our
game of the year from 2001 Grand Theft
Auto 3 glad you're here with us today
wait where's the hill there we go I
don't want to screw up this car down now
there's a bomb in it and everything time
to take it back all the brakes on this
suck
oh all those games I mentioned were also
re-released on the Vita that's cool I
have a Vita school oh wow I'm driving
like an idiot so if I get hurt that's my
fault I'm trying to be cool there's a
bomb in this car yeah I do not crush
this car says Kyle yeah no no that's
right okay wow that guy all right time
to get that F out of here I'm gonna do
this from a safe distance all right I'm
tired of these pedestrian scam that way
what it's not sick what'd I do wrong
what didn't I do
okay maybe I don't want to equip a
weapon all doing this let's see here
what do I have to do mmm that's right
used to get the physical match with
these old games remember that needs to
come in to be the mangle like to be the
bomb
get out of there tell me shoot tell me
how to activate it all right I'm gonna
try all the buncher aha okay it was
circle let's get the F out of here is
that a subaru Baja no just a regular
pickup truck - car alarm oh oh here he
comes
yeah I remember all those maps from
there
the game needs to come with the games
doctor 360 says I used to play this game
when I was in kindergarten young man oh
that also kind of sting because I was oh
there it goes I was like 11 no yeah I
was it was 11 when this came out and I
got it for my own I was like 12 holding
at 13 oh yeah it's a bobcat you know
let's go to okay
Luigi's our back to the this is gonna be
a pain huh there we go let's go back
this way
I'll be thrown on some cheats soon I
only have one for guns right now
yeah whoa
Dennis says I was 13 I still remember
almost all the car names yeah good times
on this is one of those games that you
just like there's a lot of good oh shoot
there's a lot of great open-world games
so this is one of the early ones and so
I spent like a particularly long amount
of time on this the Vice City and San
Andreas
those were my jam especially San Andreas
I think I put the most hours into that
what's the car with the flames on it the
gang won the Hermes Man the Hermes
Colorado or something I'm not really
sure who needs details anyway he's got a
noodle stand down in Chinatown that rad
has sold his last third front I want you
to take them out if you need a piece
that on your back in Chinatown it's
triad territory Oh Noah said I never had
this game hopefully you were able to
play it somewhere I mean if you're
interested this game is one of the
greats man I didn't have it right away
either I was telling Chad earlier I
played it at my with my cousin's ps2
four years before I got it like two or
three years
my first GTA game that I bought like
with my own money was Vice City but I
did play this oh yeah that's
laughs am I going this is a loop okay I
got to get in
Tyler we are playing the ps4 version
it's available on the PlayStation Store
for I think $14.99 all of them are the
and they're not the iOS ports if that
you know turned you away from buying
these there are ps2 emulation
all right almost here
streets are so empty
well okay let me see
I'm just trying to figure out a code
here there we go got my armor back mmm I
got more ammo okay I think I'm fine to
start this mission I shouldn't have a
gun at this point unless I stole it off
a cop because it were early on in the
game but I'm cheating I'm a shoe see
doctor 360 yeah I'm telling you I think
that's Michael rap before he would the
oh whoa we're getting into it oh man
those were innocent guys dang it make a
run for it Go Go Go Go Go they knew what
they were doing they blocked my car off
all right I want to take out the assault
101 guy in your car whatever happens I
just want to take him off the road shoot
the stupid grass my stuck a song rules
oh my goodness oh why am i chasing him
in a pickup truck
oh I could swap a car but I want to
focus on just keeping close to him oh my
gosh chat hang on
I want to read everything you're saying
I love all these memories where she
hurting but I'm after this fool who is
car smoking
oh come on
is he getting out he's making a run for
it on foot
oh no okay oh no another car of totally
screwed my cars on fire everything is on
fire run okay I can catch up and catch
up oh my god I'm a menace oh thank you
yeah I will turn down the radio in the
settings I forgot I can do that to avoid
turning it off every time thank you come
on I'm running out of stamina this is
full speed right now watch if I stop
running he's gonna like take a breath
know what though come on Claud
there we go that's what I'm talking
about can I reach him
they keep aiming at other people oh it's
over from very locked finally yes a cool
$10,000 for a waste in this fall whoo
that was close I'm gonna take a little
breather and chat with you guys how's it
going
a beeper I remember that I forgot all
about that any nation but you get
notification through your beeper oh man
I was tapping X to run I was trying to
but I swear I wasn't going fast enough
thank you guys use the sniper next time
but I'm not that good with [ __ ]
oh yeah let me check the radio settings
here maybe you can just turn those down
unfortunately that's part of the
nostalgia is the music but I have to
turn it down you guys know why I'm
highlighting a bill that didn't do [ __ ]
what the heck oh man
Evan Langer in the chat aw you're too
kind friend Evan I love you dude I
didn't do it I'm gonna do it alright
it's weird like the it looks simple
enough like here is the music volume I'm
trying to turn it down but it just keeps
switching over forget it
I'm wasting time I'm just gonna turn off
the radio like this alright guys
here we go next mission y'all the gang
drive-by missions were painted complete
couldn't aim on vehicles yeah he can't
he's had to pull to the side huh
everyday bullets won't even dent the
vans on my cell get a car and Ram it off
the road now hit it hard and the
punk-ass security guard should bail and
take it to the warehouse at the docks
and my guys are gonna take over from it
now I won't be doing its rounds all day
so don't hang around Sam Park you want
me to do some some side quests with a
fire truck and the ambulance a taxi
police car what do you guys think those
are fun yeah I can find some bad guys
maybe after this mission we'll try one
out one of those vigilante missions you
know I tried classic rock star games in
the chat saying turn down the music
volume I tried I'll try again later but
I felt like I was just futzing around
and wasting time I solved the menu there
but it wouldn't let me turn it down
okay I totally missed out on what he was
saying I'm just so surprised that it was
Michael Rapaport voice so causes some
trouble here okay some damage was
inflicted this is coming back to me now
do I have enough bullets man my car is
gonna get damaged first keep my distance
this is gonna take forever yeah I'm out
of bullets all right
that helped a lot more I need a new car
I got to keep up with this guy
but some in the tech yes copyright
police copyright police is here you're
under arrest
that's why I'm afraid all right I can't
shoot out of the side of the car with
this gun I'm losing them all right I'm
gonna whip out the bazooka guys I'm
gonna cut them off here
he's already hurting my cars so much all
right this will distract him a little
bit
no it didn't work
[Music]
ah now working guys I'm scared I'm
freaking the people out use the truck
with the wrong way sorry the microphone
was covering the mini-map on the bottom
left
dang it alright let me get the bazooka
ready
each head radio
I'm just doing a code here for more area
for more bullets okay it's guys going
slow good let me get ahead of them and
see if I can like bazooka
there's the Hermes car
let's go Oh what the heck I got to
listen to the damn directions I blew up
the car cuz I thought that I was
supposed to do that all right you know
what let's see here
oh shoot now the police are on cops are
on the yellow
let's see maybe we go back to we do that
one of those Luigi missions ah the cops
are still bugging me it's only one star
though we can we can hang
oh so my old car it is
here we go I stuffed a bazooka in my
hand you have to hit the car with your
own car no bullets
I believe you your name on this on
YouTube is classic rockstar games
I believe you man maybe I'll try that
again afterwards but my car when I
tapped it it was smoking man who is
phantom pain a retro game nah bro I
don't think so I think we're there yet
no not at all it's like this generation
all right
hey there were twins unintentionally
need a car here
baked potato game says I love this game
I played GTA 2 first when I was seven or
eight then about this game and driver oh
yeah
and I thought it was the new driver
oh here we go
I need the truck to complete the mission
aha see haven't you guys around this
makes all that easier all that much
easier what the f am I going
oh it's below me all right
haha how did I do that with our taxicab
[Music]
control they're still really good on
this tank tie one sec yo I need the
brief because I blew it again okay this
is a straight-up hit I sounds like I can
kill this guy with no problem so let's
do it oh I fell down
[Music]
let's go
William says this brings back great
memories here here man
[Music]
why would you get out well that dude is
dead watch this got him
whoops didn't mean to do that sort of
well that was easy enough Chris says I
still remember the streets I live in
Liberty City yep we've talked about that
a little earlier man we these are like
our little virtual homes we know the
layout so well after all these years ago
years of playing this animal
here we go
sampark do not in the stream with before
giving us a good fist fight with a bunch
of gang members woo I definitely will do
that I'll do that for you because I will
be outnumbered and I'll be killed but I
will give it my best shot
hey there's only one room for one of us
to be not get him to the ball they'll
make a bundle get out many of them as
you can before the cops drink away to
green okay time to go to the police ball
egg sausage McMuffin is back he says
this map is etched in my mind it is me
says best GTA ever because it's the only
one I've ever beaten holy crap
I'm on a timer I gotta go pick up all
these girls
I need like a bus what is I'm gonna blow
up my damn car anyone in the chat from
New York City let me know let me know
what you guys are from you guys know I
love doing that
here we go okay so I can pick up a total
of three I'm gonna do that before I go
this one's good thing I'm in a fast taxi
house this is what this car was made for
baby
hop in one more one more I got room for
one more lady it's like the witch which
view do you guys like oh no that's fine
whoa whoa excuse me first person NAT
doesn't feel like GTA to me that one's
fine that's memorable
okay I'm wasting time I got to pick up
all these girls let's go let's go let's
go I'm gonna go to the outer parts of
the town first to get get those done
with oh she's up there I get up there
four-wheel in taxi right here y'all whoa
what are you doing up here
oops I meant yeah
okay
I don't think I'm gonna do this in time
guys get a police car I have to start
some [ __ ] to do that but I'm down to be
faster than this
cut through cutting through
don't need that star yet geez should
have hired somebody to walk I heard me
what the hell am I talking about
should've hired a driver though someone
with a limousine
Oh God what am i doing this cars gonna
blow up and it's pulling girls here we
go go go go go go now thanks to knocked
one over now it will take a police car
police escort baby okay okay I have two
minutes to pick up like a thousand girls
this is not gonna happen
this one this lady couldn't walk look
how close she is to the PD let's go
let's go let's go all right you're in oh
I need to be aware of my surroundings
guys go go go go
this is an emergency with the wrong way
this was a good idea thanks chat hit a
police car heck yeah
hop in
I've won I'm not gonna why am I even
trying I'm not gonna do this in time
oh I was looking at the China crashed
out
here's one here's one here's one she
counts on up she's all around the corner
this Cub doesn't give it about what's
going on come on
you guys like that j-turn
this I have one minute how many are left
I can't tell
I'm not gonna do it is there like a bail
me out mission button here no I got it's
gonna if I blow a sub that'll be mission
failed
it sounds tempting
[Applause]
with the
oh this is a messy guys
these girls are trying to just go to the
party I'm freaking them all out
man how many are left this is good to
know I don't think I'll try this mission
again I might go back to the garage
instead I may be full around do some
cheats what do you guys think yeah I do
not have 12 seconds this is all back oh
dang there were only two more
is there a limousine in this game that'd
be fun what what what what the what
happened okay well I passed whatever
should I save my game and see what
should I do guys what do you want to see
shouted out in the chat yeah okay now
I'm looking at the chat you guys are
like yeah you have enough you have
enough so I beat it
woohoo I'll go back to mission here the
garage see what's up oh man that was an
old lady
okay I'm ditching this car
van heists alright alright we're gonna
hit the payroll Vince it leaves the edge
of Chinatown every day bullets won't
even dent the vans on my so get a car
and read middle road now hit it hard and
the punk-ass security guard should bail
and take it to the warehouse at the
docks and my guys are gonna take over
face Tyler I'm here now I won't be doing
its round 2 all day so don't hang around
hey what's up she lived a full life yeah
that old lady yeah didn't mean to run
her over someone one nice way to look at
it there now I need a car again let's
see here watch out here we go taxi ok me
a strong car you guys were suggesting
the truck earlier and this guy already
kicked me out of the cab I was trying to
jack oh now we're fighting and it's over
maybe a van you guys suggested a truck
earlier maybe he's trying to find
something I need something tough here we
go
there's a nice truck ok guys wish me
luck on this mission this time now I got
a little more idea what to do here
there it goes I will gently tap this
gonna take forever isn't it alright
let's see let's see how much this in
flakes I hadn't actually took a bigger
chunk than bullets did
there we go yeah I'm already smoking
though guys they made this truck go slow
on purpose because I gotta keep
switching cars huh
Oh hover wait anyway I passed another
one but I want this one let's go let's
go go
no I like your car get out of the way
cool he's right around the corner
corner him huh
oh that did a lot of damage have I seen
the greatest story never told you I'm
afraid I have not oh forget him
my car's steaming though oh man I forgot
it
cops are after me now's like not the
time you stupid pop oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
there is this cornering him enough for
you there he's out the damage bar is
gone did you run away now just take it
right
they're gonna light me up
this one I must stake no time for cool
music right now
[Music]
whoo
this thing is slow no wonder
go go go go
[Music]
[Applause]
here we go I'm gonna blow our friends
cover whoa
no I'm so close get away yeah oh here we
go
I don't know how guys but I did it
actually I do know how thanks to y'all
get out of the vehicle
oh I can breathe big sausage McMuffin
says the best time for cool music that
was the best time for cool music I just
had to turn it off you guys know already
in it Dan wants to offer you an
opportunity
to a payphone yeah someone said that in
chat earlier that's right beepers and
payphone
[Music]
let's go
sampark I remember that shooting the
moon with a sniper rifle changes the
size of it that started here for some
reason I thought that just started and
by saying but I trust you
let me pick up this Hummer
he's mad oh yeah it's called the Patriot
[Music]
how is this really block okay not really
Oh cuz there's a pothole you should have
list this is a mess good thing I have
the Hummer there's a payphone
what is this hill there it is a song
Danny says San Andreas was good with the
first two on the ps2 were great
hell yeah man you guys know how shitty I
Drive this is gonna be a disaster
let's see you all get a fast car that
car was pretty fast by thinking that's
too far now taxis are fast oh look of
course there's a Hermes and see like
another one whatever I want this one
this is fast enough
where was that Banshee yeah I need the
Banshee now shoot hey I'm getting jumped
out of my car
[Applause]
just turn off the radio and options I
tried I fiddled around with it but uh
weird they wouldn't let me turn it down
let me try again because I do want to do
that it is easier just as a whole so
going to audio and then oops see there's
a music volume there it is clear as day
but I'm trying to I'm hitting left to
turn it down okay I had to hold it it
seems that was great
problem solved thanks Chet okay this
card is fast enough and I don't remember
where the Banshee rut is off the top of
my head and I don't have the map but
let's see if that'll work with the the
Hermes with the flame paint on it oh I
forgot how slippery the Hermes car is
though we'll see
and I forgot how much I suck at driving
in this game okay guys
man yeah they have like super cars you
weren't kidding I needed the Banshee at
least oh well at least you can see how
bad this is gonna turn out
oh my cars heavier though at least
wait I already screwed it up guys oh my
goodness gracious
I already screwed it up I was I was
looking at the other check mark how did
no one roll over yet huh I think this
will be the last race I'll be
participating in for obvious reasons
yeah I think all the pay phone missions
are race related missions and I'm no
good at racing without the right car
yeah look no way this is oh my judge
forget it and I missed my turn look at
all the cars going by what if I just
fail out and like blow up my car let
them finish the race huh I don't think
I'm gonna I don't think I'm gonna hang
with these boys
you know remember how you can flip your
car in this game you can't roll it over
and you can't uh once you roll it over
like there's no chance you can kind of
topple it back over like in GTA san
andreas if you if you shimmy the
joystick in and those games you have a
chance to flipping your car over but not
in this game hey it's the first time I
died that's pretty cool wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
okay so I'm not gonna do that payphone
mission again they're probably like
we're disappointed in you
man whoopsie-daisy
this guy you really wanted his cab back
or he's gonna find me for it oh okay
whoa well after we did that a mission
with this guy over here and should have
a new one ready for us Capri Anees
chauffeur Oh
Oh I listen to sky in Italian and he's
no mechanic but it could get things
fixed this is pops capo toni cipriani
Cipriani take him to mamas restaurant at
st. marks all right now listen to me I'm
planning a job that needs a good driver
so drop by sometime later okay okay kid
drive me to the laundry in Chinatown
first I got a bit of business to take
care of those washer women ain't been
paying their protection money who watch
the car Joey just fixed this junk heap
so an old fancy crap mean oh well here
we go come on in the chat hello guys
Merry Christmas
cool hey thanks for joining us Maude
good to see you again all right time to
be careful with this car
whoa
[Applause]
skirt
that's a nice bar
boy I said it before and I'll say it
again this map is a little smaller than
I remember maybe because I'm used to the
Liberty City that's in GTA 4 but this
feels a lot smaller feel like my
missions are never that far away it's a
good thing though
perfect for stream
Here I am wait here keep the engine
running this ain't a social call okay
hmm that guy's walking okay I was like
that guy's walking around with a bat
spits Cipriani Oh No
oh now and of course go go go go great
drive
they didn't give me a good car for this
life
maybe this way take the outer way here
boy this is nice that there are no cars
on the road gosh but so close looked the
pink spot is right there
now I started a traffic jam Marco says
ah the memories thanks for joining
tons of memories in this game this was
our game of the year 2001 well made a
cool 3,000 bucks and I get to keep this
car no way and now I get to work for him
let's see what he's got huh okay
the Triads think they can mess with me
let's teach these would be tough guys
what it means to be a tough guy yes
Marco I'm playing with the ps4 losing
the ps4 controller mangle any triad [ __ ]
that gets in your way
eight-ball can supply you with what
you're gonna need a ball is our friend
and the gift that keeps on giving huh
almost 20 years ago yeah whoo
this was a early memories for the
PlayStation 2 for me whoa
lots the same carbon that's the G that's
the GTA rule right you pick up a car you
finally want and then you see a billion
of them that's a GTA logic I mean
all right told me to mangle them
I just ran right into the back of that
truck good board
I'm ready blowing it okay they're all
here look back and I'm out of bullets
you see if I can just pull him out of
his truck now in this mission I feel
like you won't stop Willie
okay
well now yeah I wasn't whoa
I think I'm supposed to not take it
anywhere but so much as blow it up so
let's do that huh I need weapons
just inputting the code aha if I blow it
up and I wasn't supposed to know I'm
supposed to I hurt myself with the
process now the cops are oh my goodness
blew it that cop is just chillin waiting
for me
still more work to do get my way cops
no no no no boy I should have looked up
that like that cheat to get the cops off
me huh that's alright I don't know if I
can lose them at the 3 star level but
I'm sure gonna try there's a helicopter
over my head
[Applause]
it was bold I thought I would try but at
least for sure I know what to do
mm how are we doing in chat you guys
it's ready for the you guys get a I was
a weird glitch who's got some time off
for the holidays huh are you guys gonna
do you guys gonna play anything you can
play this it's pretty cheap on
PlayStation 4 okay I don't want that
card so slow I'd rather run yeah I
should have gone to the pain spray huh
they open to meet you here alright back
to Tony first of all actually before I
do any of that let me make sure I got
enough weapons maybe do add some health
here there you go I love them
continually flipping them off it doesn't
matter some more weapons here
yeah
let me Rockettes should be more than
enough 10 yeah let's get this started
come on yeah everyone out of my way
please
eggs sausage McMuffin says looking at
playing Cod and Red Dead 2 both great
games both great games I hope you hope
you get around to doing that especially
red did my goodness the story in that
game is incredible what here we are
I'll just skip this this time yeah every
Rockstar game especially and every hand
model looked like this that's how they
just like they were glued together just
like you said that's perfect
no no thank you
all right maybe I can do this
smarter here nah GTA I'm gonna blow him
up and run for my life oh there he is I
was like we're the hell
okay a bunch of cops I'm gonna wait here
what's the song we are playing at the
PlayStation 4 version
okay so he won't stop oh there's two of
them
I go all out with the bazooka here well
I stopped one of them let's see here I'm
gonna blow up my car in the process but
worthy
look afresh taxi right here no cops on
me yet
going going I'm going for it where is
this guy making a delivery - anyway we
are out here
these this one's scared they probably
won't
oh [ __ ]
dangit yeah man I got a star though I
got a star gotta run gotta run just one
star at least I'm not timed on this
mission huh one more truck this is a
dead-end area whoa
Brenden yeah we will be having our
podcast right we will we made it I
believe the team made a few to keep over
the break schedule you know so it should
be scheduled as normal so stay tuned
thank you for listening to the podcast
by the way the podcast is great it's on
like every week they made a few this is
good okay
gonna avoid the pothole well there's two
very good
great there's a cop right here hmm he's
far enough
scuse me Wow
$20,000 scar says what great memories
yeah so many memories with this game the
sound kind of goofed up you guys hear it
egg sausage McMuffin played so much san
andreas just taking pictures of weird
[ __ ] I forgot you get the camera at one
point yeah good times with that game - I
would say that's of these three of the
PlayStation 2 era the san andreas is my
favorite close second though is uh
they're all so good I don't know man and
your car with a lunge I'm just like here
like so nostalgic and there's the
perfect car getting away no yes
got that speed
was there ever snow in this game I don't
know I don't remember it would make
sense East Coast is full of snow New
York especially Liberty City but this is
our mod what am I thinking over you guys
tell me if you guys remember there being
snow in this game or something like a
way they patched it in maybe the PC
version there's a lot of old people in
this game I never wonderful run over
them if I don't need to the laundry has
agreed to pay you did real good kid go
collect the cash and bring it back here
watch out for the Triads they may be
shoving a firecracker up your ass
but don't take no crap well buddy I mean
nobody messes with Tony Capri Ani Tony
Capri Ani the other guy said Cipriani I
don't know what that's him so let me say
Capri Ani that's coming from the mouth
of Tony Capri Ani
well I did a good job excuse me sir
always some of you guys are saying by
city was the best hell yeah
Oh liberty City Stories had snow maybe
that's what I'm thinking of
it's nice having a bunch of you here to
like clarify all this information I
don't know every answer about these
games but someone down there does in the
chat it's always very helpful Pepe you
guys are here all right
so many of the my thinking of Yakuza
they have a scene like this in an alley
oh man oh man well I have the gun cheat
on it's a trap Oh Helen she just started
right away whoa whoa I'm dead it won't
lock on well
Lisa know what to expect what gun would
you guys use that shotgun I thought it
was too it didn't work out as well as I
thought that was like the spaz 12 or
whatever no go for me eggs sausage
McMuffin thanks so much it says you're
killing it with these throwback streams
any excuse to play these old games fine
by me
they were our game of the year that's
the that's what we're going with it's
true there were games of the year for a
reason yesterday we had a great time
playing ocarina of time tomorrow though
we will be playing our game of the year
this year which is sick hero rip yeah I
got laid off just you died sweet right
there's a cost stuffed with a stiff at
the cafe in the Akeley
nothing stiff one of the Forellis
thought he was a wise guy so he got what
he had coming to him take the corpse to
the crusher and haul wood all right
there's my car
let's roll
oh my gosh yeah let's roll right into
ole woof woof mr. son of the police I
wish help me help me pronounce her name
I would love to shout that out in the
chat every time we flip on the sirens in
this game yet I think of that - oh you
guys like that guy's accent I forget his
name Jay we just call him Jay
it's the forelli brothers' Oh
of course I got a tail oh my god
we're gonna crush the F out of this car
geez maybe why can I just throw it in
the Hudson River play twisting middle
black you know what who said that in the
chat rock Austin I downloaded it because
I could you know I wanted to do that but
we ended up picking these games it was
uh there was a small final list I had to
condense I only had three days to do
this so we picked GTA over twist the
meadow black but I downloaded twisted
metal black it's on the PlayStation 4
right now at the end of the Year sale
four bucks or something like that like
under five bucks I downloaded it so fast
twist the middle black though I am gonna
play the alpha break I haven't played
that since move back in the day good to
know you guys would like to see that
though who let me we have any twisted
metal fans in here we have to twist
metal to is my favorite close second is
black puts the metal black rules they
still following me
oh yeah they are the vehicle hey get
back in the vehicle
oh yeah I didn't put the tiny cheats on
I'm gonna get shot up okay
got some guns no shotgun this time there
it goes ha ha ha that was great
okay that was pretty badass I lost some
help but hey look I got a trophy
disposing the evidence Oh No yeah just
raise guys hear that fire rate unreal I
hear someone else talking someone else
is around here hmm
catching up with a chat here thing
well that was the car oh I can use this
van to get out of here
oh yeah you can't run with the shotgun
too heavy guys take it easy in the chat
what are you guys doing what is all this
off okay here we go
twisted metal black was on sale for
three bucks on the ps4 in the last two
weeks sale and tomorrow get on it see
that's what I was trying to say that the
game was dirt cheap right now and it's
on the ps4 end of the Year sale go for
it
[Music]
oh my god traffic jam okay we're back
here at tony's me see if i get some
health what's the chief read it's now I
got more bullets doing that but I forgot
the health code we should be fine right
the laundry has agreed to pay you did
real good kid oh this is the mission I
can do bring it back here watch out for
the trial man okay maybe shoving a
firecracker up your ass yeah we know
okay um what's the best tactic I think I
will use I need it something okay maybe
this this is nice and fast a little easy
here the mac-10 whatever this is Magnum
what let me get the hell
no you know what I'm just gonna do it
alright guys wish me luck time to time
to go back and fight those guys I think
a technique I'm gonna try this time just
run a little further from them so that
the lock-on works better I was
surrounded so fast
what time is it though you know what we
have 10 minutes after I tried this
mission let's just go all out with the
cheat see what we can find and have a
little fun huh for me I'm having fun but
let's break the rules shout out in the
comments what kind of cheats you guys
want me to use that levitating one all
the tanks get the Rhino up in here
angry pedestrians there were millions of
cheats for this game okay wish me luck
guys
we go I might take that route that route
only has one guy okay they're getting
too close that was the problem last
hmm surrounding me again one more one
more
oh look at that oh yeah I almost died
time to get the F out of here oh and
take their truck hell yeah something
have to take their truck just kill that
guy
going back to Tony's planes okay wish me
luck now the cops are on my tail oh my
goodness Oh having a truck helps the
weight the weight of this truck that
can't tip me over so easily
we made our money friends Oh
cops toll on me there's one learn to
drive
no no no yeah see how fast he ran in
there great okay
we pass the mission the cops go away
that's great I love when that happens
let's look up some cheats huh
go a little crazy full armor whoo random
outfit rays wanted level increased gore
crazy improved car skills blow up all
cars spawn a tank bingo that's what I'm
starting with let's let's me ruin
everything here okay I'm gonna put this
down for a sec so I can see hopefully we
get this going
[Music]
that didn't work and I had to fire off
some rounds to do that maybe you need
more space
come on is there a right key I forget I
know there's one in San Andreas but I
forget if you can make pedestrians angry
in this game all right let me unequip a
weapon here and try the tank code again
riot and tank says the oyster ok that's
a good start
whoops I hear it I hear it
yeah oh my goodness okay
actually I'm you get out of this first
while I'm still under the radar and get
out some angry pedestrians here you guys
can look at it
while I get the coke going one ah there
it is
[Music]
here we go this one's called pedestrians
hate you I'm just gonna go with that ooh
pedestrians fight each other crazy put
it crazy pedestrians with weapons that's
what I'm gonna do okay here we go
link looks weird what temple is this no
that was yesterday
[Music]
oh dang it someone got in the way of me
doing my code I don't think I fudged it
up here you know what I'll try this one
more time if not I'm gonna just cause
some destruction make the
pedestrianisation
there we go they should have guns now or
soon for now I got the Rhino here we go
[Music]
yeah can this thing flip around the yes
it can this makes you go faster oh I
love it
time for a full speed tank here but the
finished piece she didn't work in it
oh wait they do have guns but they're
not fighting each other yeah this is
what GTA is all about right how many
hours did you guys spend just doing this
some people didn't even finish the game
because this is this is what it's all
about you oh my goodness there's the
terror that okay let me face this thing
forward and actually destroy some cars
that I can see
this is what comes to my mind when I
think of GTA 3 like Liberty oh yeah the
one that takes place in Liberty City oh
yeah
yeah only three stars time to turn it up
cyborg man chimes in he says his game is
an all-time classic
the game that started it all he said
and I wish I can hand you guys the
controller whoa
tell us place is a game audio too table
guys um you know there's a lot of radio
chatter when you turn it
[Music]
I turned down a ladle but let me know
you guys tell me why the rot haha fly
the tank into the next city then okay
how much time we have left there is a
I'm sure there's like that levitating
flying code but if I stop if I stop
these guys are gonna arrest me so let me
look up that code first pedestrians hate
you cloudy weather fast motion blow up
invisible cars where is it we only got a
few minutes anyway guys so let me just
cause some more destruction our our last
goal here before we wrap why don't we
try to get to six stars
excuse me it'll be tank versus tank we
speed up this is fun
both Army's coming in thank
no I thought those were just regular
trucks I thought there were the army
trucks
you nut the ambulance see the
pedestrians that you have guns are
barely using about five stars I'm sorry
six stars sake stars do a sick jump let
me find a ramp so I can flip this around
my little chica
get some speed let's try to do a sick
jump that's for you egg sausage McMuffin
Oh manly Oh
I do not want to flip this thing over is
that a ramp that's a stairwell [ __ ]
well he's indestructible
[Applause]
oh no a fire hydrant really did mean wow
you guys oh no I'm screwed
I could start that mission but I'm gonna
end with a bang
no I'm not gonna able to thing I have no
guns I'm gonna run for my life
this is it guys we had a great run
together all right Pete good timing too
we're gonna wrap up there this game is
available on PlayStation 4 this is how
I'm playing today you guys ever want to
go back down memory lane it's like 15
bucks I think thank you all for joining
me really appreciate you having here
having you here tomorrow we will be
playing switch over
haha there we go tomorrow we are gonna
be playing SEC euro that's our game of
the year this year thank you guys for
watching today and I'll be back tomorrow
see ya wait yep bye